Afganistán es un país... difícil en todos
sus aspectos.Y, sí, decir esto es quedarse
muy cortos.
Fijaos, Afganistán es un país muy montañoso.
Casi las tres cuartas partes de su territorio
están cubiertas por montañas y picos, que
ojo, en muchos casos sobrepasan los 6.000
metros de altura.
Ya os podéis imaginar lo difícil que resultan
aquí las comunicaciones entre las diferentes
regiones del país.
Por si fuese poco no tiene salida al mar,
y la mayor parte del terreno es árido. Los
desiertos no son aquí un ecosistema precisamente
extraño.
Vamos,que exceptuando algún que otro valle
como el de Herat, lo que aquí abunda de verdad
en el paisaje nacional son los tonos rojos,
ocres y amarillos.
Pero... lo peor de Afganistán no es su orografía
ni las duras condiciones climáticas, para nada
Lo peor de este país es la pobreza, la corrupción
y sobre todo el fundamentalismo y la violencia.
Porque, amigos, Afganistán es sobre todo
un país en guerra.
(Fijaos, en 1978 se produjo la Revolución
de Saur, una revolución de corte comunista,
un año más tarde, en 1979, el ejército
rojo de la Unión Soviética invadió el país
para consolidar al gobierno comunista… pues
bien desde entonces los afganos no conocen
la paz.)
Ojo, tampoco es que antes estuvieran muy bien…
Afganistán era, es y probablemente será
por mucho tiempo uno de los países más pobres
del mundo y con unas condiciones de vida más
duras y hostiles, especialmente para las mujeres.
(En este país 6 de cada 10 personas no saben
leer ni escribir, prácticamente la mitad
de la población no tiene acceso a agua potable
y es raro encontrar una familia que no haya
sido azotada por la guerra y la violencia.)
Creo, amigos, que podemos decir que Afganistán
es uno de esos países donde es mejor...
no nacer.
Pues bien, el último gran conflicto, que
aún hoy perdura, estalló en octubre de 2001
cuando el Presidente de Estados Unidos, George
Bush decidió invadir Afganistán como respuesta
al 11S.
Por aquel entonces el país estaba dirigido
por los talibanes, un grupo religioso-político
tremendamente radical que daba cobijo a los
miembros de Al Qoeda, entre ellos a Ben Loden.
La invasión fue relativamente rápida...
los talibanes no eran obstáculo para la impresionante
maquinaria de guerra norteamericana.
Ahora bien, desde entonces…
Han pasado 16 años y tres presidentes, en
la que algunos llaman la guerra más larga
de la historia de Estados Unidos. Ni siquiera
en la Guerra de Vietnam Estados Unidos pasó
tanto tiempo.
Y es que aunque parezca mentira… Estados
Unidos no está… “ganando”.
(¿QUÉ ESTÁ PASANDO?)
Dieciséis largos años de conflicto y ocupación;
y cientos de miles de millones de dólares
después, parecería lógico pensar que Estados
Unidos y la OTAN tendrían controlada la situación
y que Afganistán estaría en vías de alcanzar
la paz ¿no os parece?
Pues… nada de eso. Lo cierto es que cada
día que pasa los talibanes recuperan terreno.
Fijaos en este mapa del Washington Post: las
zonas coloreadas son las zonas de control
que tienen los talibanes.
(Y, ojo, porque este mapa refleja cuál era
la situación a principios de 2017.
Hoy las cosas serían aún peores, porque,
como hemos dicho, los talibanes están recuperando
terreno casi cada día.)
Las últimas estimaciones hablan de que el
gobierno de Kabul, Estados Unidos y la OTAN,
controlan ya menos del 60% del territorio.
Sí, el próximo mapa será todavía más
rojizo.
(“El gobierno afgano controla solo el 57%
del territorio”)
Pero… la pérdida de control del gobierno
afgano, y por tanto de Estados Unidos, no
solo se observa mirando el territorio, también
con la economía.
Por ejemplo, podemos preguntarnos ¿cómo
se financian los talibanes? ¿De donde obtienen
todos los recursos que necesitan para dar
batalla?
Pues, fundamentalmente… de la producción
de heroína. Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis.
Afganistán es el mayor productor mundial
de Opio que es el ingrediente básico de la
heroína.
Ojo, porque no es solo que Afganistán sea el mayor
productor mundial, es que controla entre el
80 y el 90% de toda la producción mundial
de Opio.
(Por cierto, ¿sabeis de donde se extrae el
opio?
Pues... de la adormidera, una planta que hoy
como podéis imaginaros es el cultivo nº1
de los agricultores afganos, y sí, en este
país la mayor parte de la población vive
en el campo.)
Podemos decir que la inmensa mayor parte de
la economía afgana depende de dos sectores:
los soldados internacionales y el opio. De
hecho, hay poco más.
Pues bien, desde hace tiempo los talibanes
controlan la producción de Opio en este país.
Pero ahora, además, se han dado cuenta de
que también pueden producir ellos mismo heroína,
que es mucho más lucrativa.
(“El opio recolectado se transforma aquí.
[...] Los talibanes reciben mucho más dinero
si transforman el opio antes de que salga
del país”. William Brownfield.)
Ojo, porque las estimaciones hablan de que
los talibanes podrían recaudar con todo este
negocio unos 3.000 millones de dólares cada
año.
Y eso a pesar de que Estados Unidos se ha
gastado un montón de dinero en tratar de
combatir estas operaciones.
Un esfuerzo que como podéis ver en este gráfico
no ha servido para nada:
Bien, gracias a todos estos recursos
los talibanes están logrando mantener una
guerra que no solo les está permitiendo ganar
territorio sino que también ha sumido al
país en la violencia.
Y lo peor de todo es que los pronósticos
no son nada buenos.
("Los talibanes son cada vez más fuertes,
el gobierno está en retirada, están perdiendo
terreno para los talibanes día a día", dijo
Abdul Jabbar Qahraman.)
Un dato: el “ejercito” talibán a pasado
de estar formado por entre 2000 y 10.000 soldados
en 2005 a más de 60.000 hoy en día.
Pero, llegados a este punto hay una pregunta
obligatoria ¿Por qué Estados Unidos está
perdiendo? o al menos ¿Por qué no se está
ganando?
(LA TRAMPA AFGANA)
En Afganistán, Estados Unidos ha probado
muchas estrategias diferentes, pero parece
que nada funciona.
De hecho, en general, existe bastante pesimismo
sobre este conflicto. Casi nadie habla ya
de ganar, sino de perder o no perder.
Y no es una cuestión sólo de más o menos
soldados.
(Cuando Barack Obama era candidato repitió
hasta la saciedad que Afganistán “era una
guerra que había que ganar”.
Cuando llegó a la Casa Blanca puso sobre
el terreno a 100.000 soldados estadounidenses
y otros 40.000 de la OTAN. Pues ni aun así).
Es verdad que muchos dicen que el problema
es que Obama en todo momento insistió en
un calendario de salida, que era algo así
como decirle a los talibanes… Ey… oye,
que todo esto es... temporal.
Pero, lo cierto es que más haya de ello,
los soldados de la coalición internacional
ocupaban las zonas pero no conseguían influir
en el terreno. ¿Por qué?
Primero porque hablamos de un país tribal,
con una cultura de la violencia muy consolidada.
No es fácil para las tropas internacionales
ganarse la confianza de la gente, distinguir
a civiles de guerrilleros o saber siquiera
qué está pasando en el terreno.
El salto cultural es… enorme… y además
tantos años de violencia actúan como una
especie de protección para los talibanes…
ya están habituados a la intensidad de la
guerra.
Por otro lado está la corrupción y el descrédito
del gobierno. Veréis, el gobierno afgano
carece prácticamente de instituciones que
puedan aportarle nada a los afganos,
y encima las pocas que existen son extremadamente
corruptas. De hecho este es uno de los países
más corruptos de todo el mundo.
("A los afganos corrientes no les gustan los
talibanes. Pero el Gobierno afgano les gusta
aún menos. [...] La gente no muere por un
ejército, muere por su país. ¿Y quién
quiere morir por el Gobierno afgano actual?
Dexter Filkins.)
Entre esto y el miedo a los talibanes es fácil
entender porque cada mes, ojo, cada mes, desertan
casi 4.000 soldados y policías de las fuerzas
de seguridad del gobierno de Kabul.
Luego, hay que decir que la parte de la estrategia
de Estados Unidos que tiene que ver con el
gobierno afgano, con la política, con las
instituciones… no ha funcionado.
Washington ni siquiera ha conseguido que el
ejército afgano funcione, exceptuando las
fuerzas especiales formadas por 17.000 soldados
de élite que son los que prácticamente están
combatiendo a los talibanes.
Sí, así es. Obama entendió que la guerra
en afganistán tenían que llevarla a cabo
los afganos aunque Estados Unidos pagará
las facturas y les diese cobertura aérea.
Entre los problemas está también Pakistán
al que se acusa de dar apoyo a los propios
talibanes, una economía que no carbura y
un montón de intereses encubiertos.)
Por ejemplo ¿Se os ha ocurrido qué interés
tienen Pekín, Theran o Moscú en que esta
guerra termine? Tened clara una cosa, estos
países no quieren que Afganistán sea una
especie de colonia norteamericana.
Por todo ello, tras casi 16 años de guerra,
la lucha continúa. Pero ahora, en la Casa
Blanca hay un nuevo Presidente, Donald Trump.
(DONDE DIJE DIGO, DIGO DIEGO.)
Trump lleva años diciendo, por activa y por
pasiva, que la guerra de Afganistán es un
monumental error, que Estados Unidos tiene
que largarse de allí.
Lo dijo, en su canal de comunicación favorito,
en Twitter muchas veces, lo repitió una y
otra vez: 2011, 2012, 2013… así hasta la
campaña  de 2016.
Por supuesto no pasó por alto la oportunidad
de meterse con Obama.
Y, ojo, no era solo Twitter, Trump insistía
una y otra vez: Afganistán era un error.
Mirad, mirad.
Y claro, en
la campaña electoral prometió que saldría
de Afganistán.
Pero… ahora que es Presidente… bueno,
parece que las cosas han cambiado.
LA NUEVA POSTURA DE TRUMP.
El pasado lunes 21 de agosto, desde la base
militar Fort Myer de Virginia y en horario
de máxima audiencia Trump explicó su nueva
estrategia… y… bueno, digamos que todo
lo que había dicho durante años quedó en
nada.
La nueva estrategia de Trump se parece tanto
a la de Obama que cuesta distinguirlas.
Trump anunció más tropas, pero tampoco muchas
más...
(Básicamente, el contingente pasará de unos
12.000 soldados actualmente a unos 16.000,
se dará prioridad al entrenamiento del ejército
afgano y a la lucha contra el terrorismo,
se pondrá más dinero, se combatirá la corrupción,
se perseguirá a los malos, ah y se presionará
más a Pakistán…)
Vamos, en otras palabras… más de lo mismo.
Nada que Estados Unidos no haya hecho hasta
ahora.
(En lo que sí hay diferencia respecto a Obama
es en dos cosas: una que no habrá plazo de
retirada, y dos que Trump parece que pasa
de todo eso de construir instituciones afganas.
De hecho, con los recortes que va ha hacer
en el Departamento de Estado, Trump apuesta
claramente por las armas respecto a la política.)
Y la verdad no está claro cómo Trump espera
conseguir con unos 16.000 hombres lo que Obama
no pudo con 140.000 o cómo piensa estabilizar
un país sin instituciones que se ganen a
la gente o que permitan cierto desarrollo
económico.
La media de edad en Afganistán es de poco
más de 18 años, es decir, la población
es muy joven, jovenes que hoy por hoy no tienen
trabajo ni futuro más allá de los talibanes.
Si Kabul y Washington no son capaces de construir
un marco de oportunidades para todos ellos…
el fin de la violencia parecerá muy lejano.
Pero claro… esas cosas a Trump.
En fin, 16 años después, y tras decenas
de miles de bajas, entre militares y civiles,
y más de 800.000 millones gastados, Estados
Unidos continúa empantanado en lo que muchos
llaman la trampa de Afganistán.
Y la verdad, Trump no parece proponer nada
diferente. Sin instituciones y sin una apuesta
multilateral que tenga en cuenta a los propios
vecinos de Afganistán… como China, parece
muy difícil que las armas sean suficientes.
Lo que sí parece claro es que Trump
es el populista que parecía ser en campaña.
En fin, turno para tí ¿Qué crees que debe
hacer Estados Unidos en Afganistán?
Dejanos tu opinión en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta. Si te ha gustado el vídeo
dale a like y no olvides suscribirte al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.